the direction of the vector okay is the
angle that the vector makes with the
horizontal so you can see here this is
our angle and we'll denote it by the
Greek letter theta so it's the angle
with the horizontal so you can see we
have a right triangle here and you can
see that the vertical component okay
that's the Y component of the vector the
horizontal component okay that's the X
component of the vector you can see we
have a triangle that's formed here a
right triangle so just like we learned
in trigonometry opposite over adjacent
is tangent so what we can do here is
write the tangent of theta equals
opposite over the adjacent which in this
case is the Y component of the vector
over the X component of the vector and
then to solve for theta all we have to
do is take the tangent inverse of both
sides so tan inverse of Y over X and
that's going to give us the angle of our
vector so in this case you would have
theta equals tan inverse of opposite
adjacent 4 over 3 and put that in your
calculator and that's going to be your
angle of your vector so very easy just
if you get a little bit confused by this
just go ahead and make a triangle and
you'll be able to see the sides of the
triangle the angle here the right angle
and just use your sine cosine and
tangent but if you want a formula just
think of the angle as the tangent
inverse of the Y component of the vector
divided by the X component of the vector
so I'll see you in the next video